[Music]
Akuma breaks all the rules for he's in
Tekken but he's not attacking care of
him
oh my god I just looked up at the bar
and look at the wall here that's gonna
do a ton of damage is that gonna be the
full mock God the whole energy part
depleted
he's been cheap since the moment he was
in the game Akuma was the best even I
was asking for naps well I think he
needed more though for for for with oh
my god jumped out right in his face he's
got some meter and he's gonna speak no
let's go
I company was seeing it look at the life
bomb oh my goodness
he brought his slipper oh oh oh
let's go the comeback
[Music]
Akuma isn't just broken
he broke takun and he may have broken it
forever 2019 was the year of Akuma for
Tekken fans from tournament top eights
to online matches Akuma was everywhere
terrorizing players and fundamentally
changing the game Akuma is one of the
most popular fighting game characters of
all time but most people know him from
his origins in Street Fighter not his
new-found Tekken dominance Akuma isn't
just popular because he looks cool
though players love and hate him because
he can do everything a fighting game
character could ever need to do he has a
fireball to keep you out an uppercut to
keep you on the ground great pressure to
keep you in the corner
crazy mobility to close the gap insane
damage and more but in 2016
Akuma made the jump from Street Fighter
to Tekken you know is during the global
finals of one of the Tekken 7 finals and
Arison Markman were there in Japan I was
watching at home is probably like middle
tonight like past midnight at least here
on the west coast and they played the
trailer alright alright alright alright
it's [ __ ] dude he's got basically in
the arcade version when he came out he
was actually broke like right now he's
just crazy strong and probably the best
when he came out in the arcade version
he was completely busted people didn't
quite know how to play the character
back then but if you give any anyone who
knows Akuma now the Akuma from back then
they would win every time Akuma was
broken in Tekken 4 a lot of the same
reasons he was so strong in Street
Fighter he had a ton of options and
crazy damage but there were certain
things that can we could do that no
other Tekken character could do things
that separate him you know make him play
more like a street fighter style you
know he's got like his crouching medium
kick from Street Fighter which is down 3
and Tekken that he can cancel into a
fireball like Tekken doesn't have
normals that you can cancel into
specials like that you know so just that
like fundamental thing was completely
different from checking you know being
able to do you know meaty timing on
things like that like existed in second
but I feel like with the kuma you kinda
have more of that because of fireball
pressure etc but the big deal for Tekken
characters was his jump he's got this 2d
jump Tekken you don't really jump around
when you're playing a kuma it's very
normal to jump around and I think that
through a lot of people off a cool blade
so much like a Street Fighter character
that huko a street fighter pro got top
three an Evo 2016 with him and that was
only ten days after Akuma had been put
in the game cowboy coming and this gets
do a lot oh my god he dropped all he's
choking it up
he's got rage Peugeot was basing it out
looking for chip maybe oh rock money
oh my god he's Matt's gonna make this
comeback happen he's right oh my
goodness
he could have caught him with the tooth
block the sweep is gonna do it buko
advancing to the winner's final like it
was it was it was the fact that you
played like a Street Fighter character
that he could just pick it up and he
could execute the combos right a lot of
checking players didn't have the speed
fighter mechanics to do the fpdc tom was
at the right time and hit him right
so Foucault just playing really
patiently playing a lot of checking off
that you can't get that far without
actually having some knowledge of the
game right release Akuma didn't last too
long
Bandai Namco decided to nerf him pretty
quickly and they nerfed him down
gradually I think something like at
least 10 grow of nerves in a row to the
point where people said oh now he's bad
it's not that he was bad it's just that
he was so much better before that in
comparison everyone dropped him I'm not
gonna play him now
none of his stuff works anymore but
despite the nerf Akuma remained one of
the most frustrating characters to play
against in Tekken 7 partly because he
had access to Street Fighter 4 his
signature mechanic the focus attack and
- cancel the FA DC the focus attack -
cancel that's a direct carryover from
Street Fighter 4 right so you can do an
uppercut for example and then you can
cancel the uppercut with a folks attack
and dash out of it right and doing that
process essentially costs you a bar
meter but you can convert that bike
yourself on the ground during the
uppercut while it launches the opponent
so it's basically a safe attempt and
launcher at the cost of meter but it
gives you a full combo afterward all
that makes Akuma truly terrifying to
play against not only can he do things
that no other character can his damage
is nuts
nobody goes to the orbital that gets
punished they're nice with what is from
the Wow look at this damage oh my god I
just looked up at the bar and look at
the wall here this is gonna do a ton of
damage is that gonna be enough oh my god
the whole energy bar depleted uh beyond
that though I still feel like the
characters damage output has always been
so high that even now like that the
character is more balanced than he was
in the past you know you get launched by
an Akuma and he does a walk on when he
does it the raging demon afterward
you're like what the hell like that was
like 80% of my life you know even like
before it would've been like a harp
Center 99% of something now it does like
75 80 percent there big calm with its
require execution but no one wants to
kids buy a combo that does damage on
your life bar oh it's party time and
chickens invited why did you say that
look
let's go I company was seeing it look at
the life bomb oh my goodness oh the
comeback so you have 200 IQ I got 200
Jeanette sure
let's go although he'd been playing
Tekken 7 for a while super Akuma wasn't
really well known outside of his home
country France but at the mix-ups 2019
Tekken grand battle super Akuma and the
world's eyes on him and Akuma sweet
super Koopa take this whoa no anybody
super cool move to usually right Bible
slinger for chip oh the demon poor oh my
god to jump back
for Chickering for heat avoided that
with that slight sidestep when he got
chipped get the dark here we go get the
pie style hey hey Tatsu Oh catches in
the duct in there we go
one big stop away one mixup oh that's
right that's gonna be super Kumar
eliminates you are you slow I and
secured himself a spot in Grand Final
nice sidestep left you've got 18 seconds
left to work with
there we go the high is being started
and he had to pause oh my god is he
gonna finish it
oh my gosh seconds oh my god I don't
know free monster vent
oh this season I'm speechless what super
Akuma accomplished at that tournament
was incredible he earned the world's
respect but even if he was a top player
all of a sudden he was still pretty much
the only Akuma putting in a work that is
until Pakistan arrived on the scene
knees in trouble right now
20:19 was a huge year for Pakistan in
Tekken after arson ashes incredible Evo
Japan win people started to take the
region seriously but unlike the rest of
the world Pakistan was big on Akuma but
I said people for Akuma was weak that's
not the case in Pakistan they noticed he
was strong straightaway the legend has
it that everyone has a pocket Akuma in
Pakistan yeah they got a great scene to
get good and yeah they have there but
they have the best Akuma's that's just
it they got the best the best players
and the best Akuma
when pakistani Akuma players like a
weiss honey and a teeth but finally made
out to events they crushed the world
with their Akuma's Akuma was Tekken's
best kept secret kept hidden in the most
remote region but it wasn't until the
pack stand the rest of the pakistan
scene arrived right i think it was taqwa
cup last year where the top eight had I
think I want to say five or six people
in the top eight who had used Akuma in
that tournament so they may not
necessarily have been Akuma players but
like they did use Akuma in that
tournament and I think probably three or
four them were Akuma Flair's so it's
really the Pakistan scene who a lot of
people didn't have eyes on you know as a
whole outside forest and ash and until
that point because we had seen a teef
but in a wise honey traveling around and
they were winning tournaments you know
they were doing well but like oh man you
know
Pakistan has a couple of good Akuma
flares and the thing about them was they
were hitting all the combos they know
how to play Tekken you know so it seemed
like whoa okay these guys are kinda like
what we've seen from super Akuma but now
there's more of them and just as
everyone realized what Akuma was capable
of Namco buffed him they lowered his
damage of it they made his combo easier
and more consistent his main as main
down tree combo
which now that meant that a lot of
people that weren't playing Akuma could
start playing him because he was now
more accessible oh yeah he's got move
moves improved and you've got made a bit
easier
all of a sudden Akuma was the king of
Tekken and most people weren't happy
some complained that he was boring to
watch not because there was pretty much
no counter place to getting massacred by
one of his combos but also because
everyone was playing him well when when
season and free happened and Akuma's
were everywhere and even legendary
players were known for their main
started playing Akuma in protests things
will make it any match hype they're like
oh Akuma's on screen so uh so instead of
watching that just complain that does
happen while some players did eventually
learn the matchup and did better against
him Akuma would still target number one
for nerfs do you think Akuma's damage
should be enough what do you think is
okay maybe this is easier
he wasn't oh yeah well I think he needs
more know and in November Namco Bandai
deliver giving a Combe a slight nerf to
his meter game but that didn't stop
shooting from winning the Tekken World
Tour where he busted up kuma just for
the grand fight
Chikara versus old side alright last day
on earth last day of the 2019 ticket
World Tour that's what this is
game on
Akuma coming out again not even so it
wasn't even paying attention
surprise the prize twt final with mokuba
we thought we were safe we were done
baby boy Clovis grab his face like aa
chicken when a Pakistan what countries
even represented right exactly
all son needs to do something big right
now he needs this round needs his round
give himself a breather give himself
another match to work with things and
possibly let me play it towards a recent
power crash it's worked out for him
before
oh the confirm the FA BC look at the
damage up there hugely for chicken to
close out the tournament to close out
the door Oh hold on don't let him do it
don't let him do it
[Applause]
one day after Chi Koreans win Akuma was
nerfed again this time taking a hit to
his frame data these nerfs especially
the meter nerf made Akuma's fpdc combo a
lot more difficult but just cuz a combo
happens less often doesn't mean people
are any less salty when they get hit by
it the thing is the things people
complain about then they're not
happening as often which is the nerve
right they shouldn't kill the character
out of nowhere but then Rina happening
as often and it's much riskier for the
Akuma player but when it works people
still see it work and we'll still got
all comers done that it's broken it's
unclear if Akuma is still the best
character in the game between his nerfs
and the addition of Leroy Smith the most
broken character Tekken has ever seen
Akuma's reign over Tekken is up in the
air
the cane the beatdown Leroy run it
through this game Mikio almost a raid
from one hit 2 to 2 but whether he's the
best or not Akuma's effect on Tekken is
undeniable he broke the rules and
changed the game forever forcing players
to completely rethink how they play
Akula paved the way for a new era of
Tekken setting the stage for other
characters who also breaks the rules of
the game like geese Howard or even
Noctis now they've added Akuma they've
added geese Howard
noctus also has that floated jump kind
of thing I'm gonna call it the 2d jump
so I think that the 2d jump is now a
mechanic that they can introduce to any
checking character going forward even
Leroy an original Tekken 7 character was
given a one-time-use item he's came
that's something that no Tekken
character has ever had before you know
now with Leroy they've experimented more
with having an item move available once
per match you know he's got his staff to
use it so that might be something we see
more of in the future Tekken 7 has
pushed Tekken to new heights ones that
fans never thought it would ever hit and
at least partially it's all because of a
coolants yo you don't see the we be a
[ __ ] I have it's a bunch of tarot cards
from persona pretty we be also I have
here it's the weave of [ __ ] I've got it
like all of us a manga die oh that's
pretty we be this is this is like X
weave it's like literally a bunch of
anime girls it's like the most weave
thing you could possibly own I think
except for like a body Melo I guess